mais là messieurs bonsoir dans un
instant nous reviendrons sur cette
allocution du président de la république
allocution en effet très importante et
qui soit dit entre parenthèses entraîné
le report de l'entretien qu'il devait
accorder jeudi à quatre journalistes sur
les problèmes de politique étrangère
visiblement la politique intérieure
depuis les élections municipales étaient
obligés de prendre le pas dans l'esprit
du chef de l'état sur les problèmes
extérieurs
mais avant toute chose revenons sur
cette effroyable catastrophe aérienne
que nous apprenions hier à peu près à la
même heure dans le courant de ce journal
c'est une catastrophe qui se chiffrent
par centaines 562 morts et 72 blessés
c'est dans l'histoire de l'aviation la
plus grande catastrophe de tous les
temps le plus grave accident ce jour
vous en souvenez avait eu lieu à
ermenonville près de paris
trois cent soixante quatre morts comment
donc deux boeing 747 le plus gros avion
du monde
un américain et un hollandais en sont
ils arrivés à se télescoper sur la piste
de l'aéroport de santa cruz aux canaries
c'est la question à laquelle vont nous
répondre de nos envoyés spéciaux
gérardmer rigaud et notre envie spéciale
aux canaries jean-claude hype au delà du
bilan au delà des responsabilités qui ne
sont pas encore parfaitement déterminé
reste l'épouvanté reste le cauchemar qu
évoque ces images prises quelques
instants seulement après la collision
des deux géants de l'aviation
commerciale
l'offre des hausses l'aéroport de santa
cruz de tenerife et redouté des pilotes
du monde entier
il figure même sur leur liste comme l'un
des plus dangereux du monde
le brouillard y est tellement fréquent
qu'il n'est pas rare que ces pistes
soient fermés quatre jours par semaine
et cela aurait normalement dû être le
cas la nuit dernière
hier soir pourtant il fallait se poser à
l'austro des hausses un attentat à
l'aéroport de las palmas l'aéroport
principal des canaris avaient obligé les
responsables à interrompre pendant
quelques heures le trafic des appareils
ici sur le schéma que vous voyez vous
pouvez comprendre comment s'est produit
l'accident
pris dans le brouillard le pilote de la
panam se serait trompé de bretelles il
aurait emprunté la première au lieu de
la deuxième pour rejoindre la piste
d'envol
à ce moment là le 747 de la klm avait
déjà commencé sa manoeuvre de décollage
et 7 à près de 300 kilomètres à l'heure
sous l'énorme poussée de ses quatre
réacteurs qui l'a heurté par l'arrière
le boeing des pannes american airways
qui se trouvait donc à ce moment-là sur
sa trajectoire
les 645 personnes passagers et membres
d'équipage qui se trouvaient à bord 72
ont survécu s'ils sont dans un état
grave
562 cadavres ont été dégagés des
décombres l'incendié était telle que 95%
des corps était totalement
méconnaissable il faudra longtemps pour
connaître les raisons exactes de cette
catastrophe
sur place pourtant les enquêteurs ont
déjà réuni quelques éléments à 14 heures
heure locale le ministre de l'air a fait
une conférence de presse pour le
gouvernement espagnol les premiers
rapports des experts sont formels la
tour de contrôle de santa cruz ne
saurait être mise en cause
ces documents ont déjà été épluchés ils
sont irréprochables
jusqu'à maintenant et se réserve des
conclusions de l'instruction on peut
avancer que la tragédie de tenerife a
été provoqué par une défaillance humaine
l'erreur d'appréciation d'un pilote tout
devait se passer normalement et ceci est
l'une des versions émises
les deux appareils se suivaient pour une
raison encore mal déterminées
l'avion de la panam a quitté son air de
délestage pour pénétrer sur la piste
principale
au moment même où de tous ses réacteurs
le jumbo jet de la klm se lançait pour
décoller la collision était inévitable
elle fut terrible les carcasses tordues
et noirci qui jonchent encore la piste
sont là pour le prouver
qu'est ce qui a bien pu inciter le
pilote américain à opérer cette
manoeuvre
on a parlé du brouillard qui tombe très
vite sur l'île et que dire d'autre dans
l'immédiat quand on sait que le pilote
du boeing américain est considéré par sa
compagnie comme l'un de ses meilleurs
professionnels
en attendant à santa cruz il ya des
morts des centaines de morts
à quelques mètres de nous cet après midi
on a déposé dans un même s'ils
recueillent les cors cals 6
et d'une mère et de son enfant enlacés
dans la mort pour toujours et avec nous
pour essayer de comprendre ce drame
un contrôleur aérien daniélou d'un
président de l'association
professionnelle de la circulation
aérienne
alors ici on de voir ensemble comment ça
a pu arriver apparemment donc d'après le
mystère de l'air espagnole
la tour de contrôle est blanchi mais
comment est ce qu'un pilote peut faire
une faute pareil est-ce que la tournée
ne le suis pas en permanence mais que tu
es dans une affaire aussi dramatique
je pense qu'il est bon de préciser
qu'une catastrophe aérienne est toujours
le résultat de facteurs aggravants
répétait en l'occurrence il y avait des
problèmes sur l'aéroport de las palmas
du brouillard sur l'aéroport de tenerife
des conditions donc qui n'était pas des
meilleures d'autre part on dit que
l'aéroport de tenerife est réputé
dangereux
on a pu savoir que certaines bretelles
d'accès était mal balisé il est possible
donc un avion par conditions de
brouillard fort se perdent sur des
taxiways sur des chemins roulement et
l'aéroport de tenerife est un effet des
plus dangereux du monde là je vois sur
une dépêche que cet accident sont
produits depuis depuis 30 ans le dernier
155 morts en 1972
est-ce qu'il ya quand même pas les
moyens pour que la tour de contrôle
suivent disons à la seconde ce que fait
un avion
oui bien sûr c'est un problème
d'équipement avant toute chose et il est
certain que nous ne pouvons pas avancer
d'hypothèses là dessus cependant on peut
dire que
un radar de sol aurait permis de
constater une anomalie
l'anomalie en l'occurrence est temps que
deux appareils se trouvaient sur une
même piste empêchant l'autre de décoller
c'est l'origine de la catastrophe quant
à dire que l'aéroport de tenerife
n'étaient pas équipés je ne me
prononcerai pas là dessus néanmoins
c'est un système qui rendent bons
services en france en particulier à orly
ligne et loudun est ce qu'on peut dire
que finalement ce genre de catastrophe
devait arriver un jour parce qu'il ya
des jumbo jet parce qu'il ya trop de
charters parce que le ciel est trop
encombré écoutez c'est une question très
embarrassante parce que les services de
sécurité aérienne sont par définition
censé apporter toutes les garanties au
transport commercial il ya 99,99 des
poussières pour une se passe rien mais
le facteur de la fatalité toujours là
j'en veux pour preuve que le transport
aérien et demeure actuellement le plus
sûr moyen de transport jean m
au nom donc sur l'allocution de valéry
giscard d'estaing une allocution de 13
minutes très dense
vous l'avez entendu au cours de laquelle
valéry giscard d'estaing attirer la
leçon des municipales et annoncé un
certain nombre de décisions première
décision la plus spectaculaire la
démission du gouvernement
démission que lui a remise raymond barre
il y à une heure à l'issue de son rendez
vous hebdomadaire
je vais présenter au président de la
république que ma démission et la
démission des membres du gouvernement
cette démission a été acceptée
le président la république vous le savez
pas où ce soir à la télévision mais
voilà le suspense aura été très court en
a et le copain puisque raymond barre
n'en est pas moins reconduit dans ses
fonctions pour un nouveau ministère
alors voyons ensemble décortiquons cette
allocution du chef de l'état oui ce donc
là la décision la plus importante
qu'elle était annoncé tout à l'heure par
le président de la république ce
gouvernement et le président de la
république lui assigne une mission de
douze mois dans 12 mois ce sont les
élections législatives donc une première
conclusion en tirer
il n'y aura pas d'élections législatives
anticipées il veut muscler il le veut
muscler et pour cela il aura trois
caractéristiques d'abord ce sera une
équipe restreinte de 15 membres
je crois qu'on peut rappeler qu'il ya vu
un gouvernement messmer qui avait été
également une équipe restreinte à 15
mans deuxièmement les ministres seront
choisis en fonction de leurs capacités
donc il n'y aura pas de dosage politique
et puis 3000 troisièmement il ya un
principe qui est nettement affirmée par
le président de la république c'est la
séparation du gouvernement et des partis
politiques
c'est dire que les ministres ne devront
plus avoir de responsabilités à la tête
de partis politiques bon ça c'est
l'aspect le plus spectaculaire de
l'allocution du chef de l'état c'est
l'aspect effectivement le plus
spectaculaire précisons quand même
encore l'émission de ce gouvernement
c'est d'abord la poursuite du
redressement économique
et puis un programme d'actions qui
portera de façon plus précise sur les
familles les personnes âgées et le
premier emploi des jeunes
il faut ajouter aussi que le parlement
sera associée de près à cette action
puisque l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat seront appelés à voter ce
programme ces décisions président de la
république les a prises
d'abord en conclusion des élections
municipales et dans la perspective des
élections législatives
il tire un certain nombre de leçons des
municipales j'ai noté au passage
quelques mots ou quelques phrases la
première leçon c'est que la france est
divisée
le président de la république refuse de
voir dans cette division un combat de
deux armées en campagne et même au
risque d'être accusé de faiblesse ou
même je crois de complaisance
il maintient le cap sur une politique un
choix volontaire et de la patience
deuxième deuxièmement deuxième leçon les
france
c'est veulent le changement c'est un
terme qui est cher au président de la
république mais il met en garde contre
le piège du bouleversement
troisième leçon est là le président de
la république ajoute qu'elle est sévère
et salutaire c'est la division de la
majorité et le président propose à
nouveau le pacte majoritaire dont il a
parlé la semaine dernière
et puis le pluralisme organisé auquel il
ajoute un adjectif le pluralisme accepté
alors très rapidement la façon de
réparer les affiches sur les façons de
préparer les législatives là le
président de la république s'engage
nettement parce que souligne-t-il
les élections engagé le même le sort du
pays et ce choix sera pour lui un choix
irrévocable
le président ne reviens pas sur ce que
sera son attitude au cas la gauche
l'emporterait
mais il faut je crois à souligner cette
phrase qui est sans doute l'une des plus
importantes ce choix dit il vous
appartiendra il sera respecté
viens donc un pacte loyal qui s'opposera
donc au programme commun avec vous alain
duhamel essayons de voir le pourquoi de
ces décisions et ce qu'elles vont bien
pouvoir changer alors d'abord la
procédure d'admission raymond barre a
démissionné aujourd'hui mais demain il
sera à nouveau premier ministre s'il
croyait alors c'est une procédure qui
était à la fois normal les solennelle
elle est normale habituel dans la mesure
où on l'avait déjà vu trois fois par
exemple y avait trois gouvernement de
pierre messmer où il y avait plusieurs
gouvernements de georges pompidou
en même temps elle et cela n'est parce
que le président giscard d'estaing
aurait pu se contenter d'un remaniement
du gouvernement de raymond barre il a
préféré qu'une démission de ce
gouvernement la formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement
c'était bien pour montrer que après les
élections municipales et après la
victoire de la gauche il essayait ce
faisant de reprendre l'initiative face
est de nature à satisfaire notre mandat
oui alors c'est nature à satisfaire
raymond barre d'abord parce qu'il est
reconduite
ensuite parce qu'il ya la tentative donc
de reprendre l'initiative et puis enfin
parce que je crois que face à trahir de
secret on peut dire que raymond barre
était assez agacé pour ne pas dire
exaspérés par les tensions perpétuelles
qui existait entre tel et tel ministre
entre telle formation est elle ministre
qui truquent était beaucoup de gâchis
beaucoup temps perdu beaucoup d'énergie
dépensée pour rien et qu' ils l'estiment
certainement ça a des chances de mieux
marcher comme ça alors justement ce
gouvernement dégage et des partis
politiques est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est le glas demi surprise de ski
leucan
bichard en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils avaient une tendance font qu'on
avait pu apercevoir depuis 1974
notamment et qui consistait à ce que les
leaders de partis politiques soit en
même temps des ministres avec des
attributions et c'était certainement une
raison de complications des relations la
majorité c'est dire que quand un
ministre d'état parlait il parlait comme
ministre d'état il parlé un petit peu
comme leader de parti politique ça
compliquait les choses incontestablement
mais qu'au fond chaque formation de la
majorité en voulez un petit peu au
ministre d'état des autres formations de
la majorité alors on peut penser qu'il
n'y aura plus de ministre d'état à la
fois comme leaders des partis politiques
en même temps avec un portefeuille
ministériel
et vous vous engagez ça veut dire que
demain ils sont plus ministre
foot et on s'engage non ne s'engage pas
puisque ces domaines théoriquement je
pense qu'on aura la liste mais a priori
la logique devrait être que ceux qui
incarnent et les formations politiques
dans le gouvernement n'ait plus de
portefeuilles puisque aussi bien
maintenant les ministres doivent être
choisis en fonction de leurs compétences
dans un secteur donné
amandine démissionnent de leur fonction
la tête d'un parti absolument sans qu'en
imaginant une dernière question alain
dumait l'esclave votre avis ce discours
cette allocution et nature a appelé à
jacques chirac parce qu'il faut bien
construire et que rien dire d'être
entendu écouté choix qu'il ya deux
aspects si vous voulez pour d'une part
le président la république fait deux
choses qui doivent être agréable jacques
chirac la première c'est qu'il l'a cité
de placement au passage comment va et
oui et la seconde chose c'est que
justement en essayant de supprimer ces
équipes contre le gouvernement d'une
part et d'autre part les animateurs des
formations politiques ça doit satisfaire
jacques chirac
en même temps il faut aussi reconnaître
que dès son premier commentaire en
conseil des ministres suivant les
municipales puis en changeant de
gouvernement c'est à dire en demandant à
monsieur bart de nommer un nouveau de
diriger un nouveau gouvernement
incontestablement valéry giscard
d'estaing veut aussi montrer que c'est
lui qui a l'initiative que c'est lui qui
détermine la stratégie et je pense que
ça une personne ne me croirait si je
vous disais que c'était un hasard que
tout cela se passe avant l'audience
qu'il accorde demain monsieur jacques
chirac et bus en attendant et pour en
terminer avec l'actualité politique
antenne 2 est en mesure de vous révéler
l'indicé des prix de février 0 7%
indices alourdi par les tarifs
l'augmentation des tarifs des dentistes
et le prix des produits pétroliers en a
dix qui
malgré cela semble satisfaire le
gouvernement nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler
par ailleurs la cgt et la cfdt demande
le relèvement du smic à 2000 le smic
pendant à 2200 francs l'étranger
maintenant et bien tous les regards sur
moscou leonid brejnev
il reçoit le secrétaire d'état américain
c'est-à-dire le ministre des affaires
étrangères saoud vans
c'est un test capital pour la détente
puisqu'il doit y être question tout à la
fois les droits de l'homme et de la
limitation des armes stratégiques peste
pour les rapports est ouest car depuis
deux mois que timika retraite au pouvoir
washington n'a guère ménager moscou et
il était intéressant de voir comment
leonid brejnev
elle est accueillie à dix mille cartes
les entretiens soviéto américain ont-ils
bien ou mal comment ce bien si l'on
tient compte que monsieur brejnev s'est
dérangé personnellement pour accueillir
monsieur vente qui n'est que le ministre
des affaires étrangères de monsieur
carter mal si l'on retient que monsieur
brejnev à commencer par admonesté
monsieur vance à qui ils reprochent les
positions caprice monsieur carter en
faveur des dissidents soviétiques
en vérité ce qui intéresse avant tout
monsieur brejnev et les américains aussi
d'ailleurs c'est de reprendre les
négociations soldes pour la limitation
des armements stratégiques
elle porte essentiellement sur les
vecteurs c'est à dire sur les moyens de
lancer les armes nucléaires et ce qui
complique tout c'est que depuis peu les
uns et les autres ont fait des
innovations du côté soviétique
le mystérieux bombardier baptisé ac fait
un retour de flamme et du côté américain
l'inquiétant cluj le missile de
croisière vendu des deux nouvelles
inventions ce n'est pas la soviétique
que l'on connaît le mieux
elle reste encore très mystérieuse en
revanche on en sait beaucoup plus sur la
cruze missiles
c'est un engin tout à fait étonnant
qu'il ne recherche pas le gigantisme
bien au contraire
si vous voulez une image les américains
ont essayé de jouer la souris contre
l'éléphant mais une souris sacrément
inquiétante
le missile de croisière c'est un peu la
version moderne des torpilles mais avec
une supériorité énorme sortie de l'eau
il de vie
une fusée capable se diriger tout seul
au ras de la cime des arbres
cela grâce à un radar intérieure et un
ordinateur possède en sa mémoire
la carte du terrain qu'il doit survoler
même si un nouveau bâtiment a été
construit même si un cours d'eau à
changer de lit le missile de croisière
peut retrouver son chemin volant très
bas il est pratiquement indétectable par
les radars ennemis de plus sa précision
et fantastique de l'ordre de quelques
mètres il peut aussi détruire une partie
d'une usine d'armement sans toucher les
populations civiles vivant autour dans
le nez du missile de croisière on peut
placer une bombe atomique très puissante
ou une charge explosive tout à fait
classique
enfin dernière précision le rayon
d'action du missile de croisière peut
être de 300 km ou de 3000 km tout en
volant la même vitesse celle d'un avion
de transport civil à réaction toutes ces
caractéristiques pose des problèmes
insolubles aux diplomates chargés de
comptabiliser les enjeux mort des deux
camps le missile de croisière et il
stratégique et il n'eut clé air doit-il
être comptés dans les 2400 missile de
l'accord de vladivostok
les américains disent non des
soviétiques disent oui pour compliquer
la situation il existe plusieurs
versions du missile de croisière après
la version sous marine de tout à l'heure
voici la version terrestre à partir de
ce bombardier b-52 est lancé la lcm
version largué par avion du missile de
croisière
cela multiplie les possibilités d'action
mais aussi les tractations diplomatiques
car une chose est aujourd'hui certaines
il est impossible de comptabiliser le
missile de croisière dans les accords
salt tel qu'il se discute en ce moment à
moscou pourtant il existe une solution
signé un premier accord dit salt numéro
2 concernant les anciens missile qui
limiterait par exemple à 2000 puis
discuté d'un autre accord 1 sur le
numéro 3 qui tiendrait compte des
missiles de croisière comme celui-ci et
des bombardiers soviétique bacs fin mais
d'ici là le technicien des deux pays
auront peut-être trouver autre chose
plus puissant plus terrifiant d'où
l'idée du président carter limiter à une
toutes les cinq ans les nouvelles
inventions dans jeunes morts
c'est peut-être là le véritable premier
accord vers un désarmement général
jean-charles willoquet toujours en
vedette le maquis de la procédure est
ainsi fait que celui que l'on a
considéré un moment comme l'ennemi
numéro 1 n'a été jugé qu'à moitié la
semaine dernière il n'avait été jugé que
pour un délit si j'ose dire mineurs et
qui lui a valu 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
mais le gros de la sphère willoquet l'a
commencée qu'aujourd'hui il s'agit de la
fameuse prise d'otage de l'été 75 au
cours de laquelle il avait enlevé au
palais de justice de paris
un substitut et un président de chambre
et blessé grièvement deux gars et cette
fois ci pour le faire il risque la peine
de mort oui c'était la chose impensable
exploit jamais réussi finalement pour
les les truands très rapidement ça je
vous raconte que sa femme était avait
été mise en liberté provisoire et que
jean-charles du lauquet avait été
traduit devant la 14e chambre
correctionnelle on se demande d'ailleurs
pourquoi on les fait sortir un homme
aussi dangereux pour lui faire répondre
d'un simple vol de voiture toujours est
il que sa femme a pénétré dans la dans
la chambre d'audience art en costume
d'avocat tel avait une grenade dans la
main plus de revolver dans la poche elle
a neutralisé en quelque sorte avec la
grenade toute la salle d'audience en
donnant les revolver à son mari qui a
menotté le président destitué tout le
monde est parti dans les couloirs les
devants les témoins les gendarmes les
huissiers deux gendarmes ont d'ailleurs
voulu s'interposer mais ville hockey au
cours d'une scène d'ailleurs qui va
qu'il a
qui va être débat qu on saura exactement
voir etc te mens s'il a vraiment voulu
tirer ou six par réaction il s'est
défendu face à un problème de fond deux
gendarmes ont été blessés très très
grièvement et n'en sont sortis dans avec
un coup de chance extraordinaire puis
willoquet toujours et que sa femme et
les deux magistrats se sont étendus dans
une voiture ensuite il est allé se
réfugier dans un parking de la rue de
belleville et puis il a laissé les
magistrats menotté au volant de la
voiture et s'est enfui voilà donc cette
affaire sur laquelle nous reviendrons
peut le faire car malheureusement n'ont
pas le temps de beaucoup consacré de nos
informations à autre chose que la
politique car je vous rappelle
l'essentiel du message de valéry giscard
d'estaing en début de journal le
gouvernement barre à démissionner mais
l'actuel premier ministre est chargé de
constituer demain le nouveau cabinet
plus restreint plus gestionnaire plus
dégagé des partis politiques
le chef de l'état a par ailleurs appelé
à la cohésion de la majorité à partir
d'un pacte majoritaire qui s'opposera
donc au programme commun pour les
élections législatives qui auront lieu à
la date prévue dans un an alors tout de
suite philippe harrouard vous avez suivi
les premières réactions
il y a quatre réactions pour l'instant
d'abord le parti socialiste monsieur
claude estier estime que c'est un
discours qui s'adresse en grande partie
à jacques chirac le président a montré
sa volonté de s'affirmer face à monsieur
chirac dit il avec un langage très
différent l'égard de la gauche dont il
enregistre le succès mais nous sommes
étonnés ajoute monsieur estier d'antan
le président a affirmé que la france
redoutent le succès de la gauche
bernard stasi le centre des démocrates
sociaux a toujours dénoncé les méfaits
de la division de la majorité
il ya toujours demandé que la majorité
s'unissent il constate avec bonheur que
le nouveau gouvernement sera chargé de
présenter un programme où la famille
l'emploi des jeunes seront
particulièrement mises en valeur
réactions syndicales celle de la cgc les
cadres de monsieur charpentier le
président de la république annonce un
plan de 12 mois qui peut être très utile
dit monsieur charpentier mais il faut
attendre avant de connaître ce plan
avant de se prononcer en matière
d'emploi remarque-t-il
il ne faudra pas se limiter aux
problèmes des jeunes mais créer des
emplois nouveaux pour tous
enfin françois longue pour le mouvement
des radicaux de gauche
au lieu de ce discours qui traduisait
son trouble profond dit-il monsieur
giscard d'estaing aurait pu se contenter
d'adresser une lettre à monsieur chirac
en prétendant que les français l'ont
approuvé
est compris et qu'il redoute le succès
de l'opposition le président de la
république sait c'est vainement à
démontrer l'absurde la dot réaction d'un
journal de 23 heures
merci philippe harrouard ce journal se
termine la météo comme seul jour à la
même heure vous avez tous assisté à une
véritable offensive du froid sur le pays
essentiellement sur le nord de la france
il a même neigé très souvent de
véritables bourrasques comme ce matin
par exemple à paris alors demain même
type de temps des gelées matinales et un
ciel variable dans l'après-midi avec
éclaircies nuages et averses de pluie ou
de neige couvrez vous bien longue et
passer une bonne soirée si possible les
coudes vingtaine de votre prochain
rendez vous avec l'information et tard
dans la soirée vers 23h30
betty du rôle aura l'occasion de revenir
sur les propos de valéry giscard
d'estaing sur l'accident de tenerife et
sur le millionième visiteur de beaubourg
déjà que nous saluons au passage bon
soir à demain